hello and welcome to the world this is
their breathing crew Magnus Martha and
I've got with me the world champion in
SM right now sitting at the top of the
world standings number one in fantasy
Premier League for the second time this
is Magnus Carlsen how are you doing my
friend
yeah let's pretend I'm still still
number one sounds good to me okay so
we're going to do a quick little fantasy
pulp or fantasy video here for the
people that have that have requested
that and there has been several people
requesting it over ten I would say
definitely over ten people have
requested this you happy about that yeah
that's good to hear would have been
ashamed there were nine people on there
number one in the world just first
quickly describe the feeling how is it
being at the top of the standings I felt
pretty good can't can't lie about that
it's the kind of thing that just makes
you go to bed with a huge smile on your
on your face just pure unadulterated yep
that's that's the one you're looking for
the question everyone is asking when it
comes to that is I know we've spoken
about this before but I think everyone
is very eager to hear this if you win
this season's fantasy Premier League
worldwide how do you stack that up
against being the world champion and
some of your absolute best best
performances on the chess table so these
are obviously very different different
things so if if you were to judge it
like what
accomplishment I'm most proud of and
would probably be be all the jazz stuff
but in terms of like what gives me the
most happiness I would say winning the
winning the FPL this season would
basically trump everything except
becoming classical world champion
obviously we don't wanna over Dinks no
no I mean it is still very unlikely
let's yeah let's just get that on the
table yeah I understand enough
statistics to to to know that even
though I'm in a good position now it's
extremely unlikely that I'm gonna win
but just a mere fact that it's a
possibility is for me at least
tremendously exciting yeah speaking
about statistics we get a lot of
questions from eager fantasy players how
do you apply statistics in your
evaluation of players in fantasy I I
think whenever you're looking at buying
a player it's you should always stick
check the statistics so if you have a
good feeling if the eye test tells you
something sure is try and confirm it
with with statistics and if the
statistics say something completely
different from what your eye test tells
you then that's probably probably a red
flag but I would say in in cases where
the answer is not obvious or there is a
little little difference by all means go
with your gut feeling and that's
something I do I do plenty of plenty of
times but I think looking at statistics
like expected goals you know key passes
heat maps and and all of these things
shots and everything just get it get as
much data as as you can and then and
then and then you can try and make a
choice
how do you see this season going forward
the last seven rounds when you're right
now you're feeling you're at fourth or
it's actually third place nine points
behind the leader how do you see this
going forward the last couple of rounds
all right you go number of ways hi
buddies very true yeah I had a pretty
pretty significant fall from from grace
the last time I was I was briefly number
one in the world so I'm very much
prepared for the possibility that that
will happen again I think it's fairly
likely that I will be in at least semi
contention for at least a few rounds I
have the remainders of my of the
unlimited transfer team that I had for
the first post Korona round four for
this one
so frankly I think my my ranking is
going to take a bit of a hit in the in
the next round because a lot of people
are already used to their wild card but
I think after that I'm gonna use my wild
card and I'm gonna I'm gonna be fine for
for the Romans so just you know shooting
this out there but the dream has to be
last game they you're in striking
distance just any striking distance last
game they that feeling has to be crazy
oh yeah absolutely
it's I think the 26th 26th of July right
that sounds right yep yeah so unless
some oh it's gonna be all the games
they're gonna be at 4 o'clock and region
time yeah I'm I'm coming down that's in
exactly one month that's gonna be
bonkers
yeah it's gonna be insane I hope I could
be playing I could be playing a
tournament them online which usually
starts that's exactly four that's gonna
that's gonna be rough that's gonna be so
rough
would that happen if the East is gonna
be the first move because the fantasy
Premier League yeah I mean I don't know
that would be I would if I if I mean as
you said just any sort of striking
distance I'm not gonna miss that so that
would be something getting your head
around something else than being in
striking distance for that first
probably probably actually quite
difficult but let's that's not let's not
jinx more than we already have
just saying if the possibility is there
that would be great
we're gonna keep it brief we're gonna
round it off by you have to give me your
top three players your favorite fantasy
players of all time and your least
favorite fantasy players of all time
yeah so I think number one is not gonna
surprise a soul its Mohamed Salah I got
him I got him from the moment he got
into the league had him from the first
game and yeah IIIi just have a really
soft spot for for him as a fantasy asset
and I mean I captain him pretty much
every round and I loved watching him
play apart from from that well I can go
with whom I don't like and I really
don't like Obama yarn I just find
Arsenal and inspiring and don't really
life - watching the team
play and I'm nothing like personal
against up America obviously but I I
just thought I don't like it and
sometimes I get him in my team but I
always always regret it so for my second
player gonna go with my boy Trent
I think that's self-explanatory in the
past few seasons always picked him over
over Robertson or or con dike when I had
the choice once again love watching him
play and I mean his credentials speak
for themselves isn't is an amazing asset
and also also a great player so do you
want me to go a bit left-field with with
the last absolutely because I would have
said that grow again as everybody loves
watching City play and Agora has been
the favorite of mine for three years
very frustrating though injuries stuff
like that but I'm gonna go with somebody
who's no longer in the league he was
only in the league for tus I think one
and a half seasons or maybe with us
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna check that
real quick I should remember this I'm
thinking really hard now so your third
favor is someone who's just now first
he's this good this is he's actually
number two so Trent is number three okay
let's go oh no no yeah yeah it was just
one of our seasons so he came into the
league in put in 2015 he set the league
on fire he only stays for one and a half
years
he's better than he's better than sedan
he is is it hot and Bulava he is
Dimitri Payet do you three point of so
the meat required is your second
favorite fantasy after after salon is my
second favorite okay
he would have claimed the top spot but I
just I just love Scylla okay so round
off the three players who yeah so number
one Mohamed Salah for reasons that are
obvious and he mean he is the also the
one who's taking me to number one in the
world twice so what's nothing nothing
but love for form oh he can blank as
many as many times he wants for the rest
of his life he's got is always gonna be
a hero to me and then number two Dmitri
Playa got him pretty much from the from
the start the the season he got in the
league always kept faith a lot of blanks
lots of amazing goals
rabona assists and just somebody who
played with with flair entertaining
player for sure yeah
scores scored an absolute banger with
with the left foot against Romania and
in opening games of Euro 2016 but he
missed France and he burned brightly but
not for for long as a fantasy player but
he will always he will always be in my
heart it's close to your heart okay with
your loss to dislike players oh this is
gonna be a boomerang number one and then
okay I'm not I'm not sure about the list
yet
but uh my my youngest part of the list
let me let me see any past players that
could be there on the list
oh this is gonna take a second this is
because the champion you're thinking
yeah the city knows right right now I
would say like assets that I Vita
dislike I mean my man is the only one I
could really think of like there's
nobody from City that I particularly
particularly dislike yeah I mean I like
I mean I don't I don't dislike so I just
don't think it's a great fantasy asset
oh okay this is okay I know I know it I
know who is number one on my list number
one on my list is puss girl girls yes
good choice he just yeah I just annoyed
the [ __ ] out of me the first season
where he was just so vastly outperforms
form his terrible he's terrible
underlying stats I mean he would I think
at some point he had like five goals on
on point five expected goals or
something like that he would it was just
really really annoying and everybody
would get him because he got a lot of
points and I was like no I'm not getting
this guy Brighton is terrible
offensively and he has no girl threat
even though he has a sister at and then
I disliked him at that point and what
made me really hate him was the time he
was away against United and got max
bonus they lost 1-0 and he got max bonus
for whatever reason and after that I'm
gonna I'm gonna hate him as a fantasy
asset forever so he's number one without
without any question yeah and then okay
so I'm loving how hard you're thinking
about this yeah I mean IIIi think this
should I should have thought about this
before but I feel like this is this is
important stuff it's important stuff let
me see who else did i do i iack hey
that's a fantasy asset so bob young he's
he's definitely on the list
um I mean we shouldn't use words like
hate but whatever dislike strong is just
like as a fantasy asset strongly dislike
okay so I have if I cannot comment up
with anything better
I really dislike Nick Pope just by the
fact he gets so many bonus points and
it's just so annoying
okay I know no I'm gonna I've got kind
of come up with something better
sorry for you guys at home but I'm gonna
come up with something better
you're the star of the show keep going
bro who can I think of in the in the
past who just annoyed me
[Music]
like their guys really annoyed me right
yes Raheem Sterling yeah
he misses so many chances it's oh but
the truth is like sterling performs
approximately as you should according to
his expected goals yeah yeah because you
feel like you should be even better than
he is but if he may like agrerro he
would be worth 20 so yeah no I mean
agrerro misses a bunch of chances as
well so it's okay I don't I don't
dislike sterling and like hating on
Starla he gets so much hate to begin
with so I mean for a variety of of
mostly underserved reasons so I don't
think so I'm not gonna say oh this is
the one okay this is this is a good one
this is because this is a player who I
think it's just universally liked okay
okay and it's it's OspA liquid Wow just
seems like a general generally good guy
ya know it was just one of those Chelsea
seasons where they kept like 12 clean
sheets in a row whatever and he was just
rack up bonus bonus points then there
was this other season where he would
play as as I think of right center half
and he would still get a bunch of assist
because assists because every single
[ __ ] cross that he put in would be
finished off by by Murata or or in
previous seasons da because they're like
like I just annoyed
I know it means so much and he he would
always get bonus points as well like I
would always try and go for and go for
defenders who have who have offensive
potential and a spooly kureta would just
outperform his expected SATs in such a
degree and get so many bonus points in
clean sheets and I never had him and it
just made me really dislike him that is
a very very fantasy way of disliking
someone so my favourites allowed one
player to and trend number three dislike
players it's far in a way post go across
on first place then as Polly quit second
most disliked and a boomerang is his
number three that's why you use so much
time on the list cost you thought about
me I was number one he was never three I
then it turned out he was number three
then I'm gonna get a message in about
let's say 18 hours and it's gonna say no
although I forgot someone that's how
that's how a good movie okay thank you
for this fantasy chat - it's been it's
been good fun and I from actually
genuinely from the bottom of my heart
wish you all the best with the rest of
the fantasy season
thanks thank you so much and if I'm
gonna if if I come up with some updated
list then I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
ping
okay are we gonna get it out on Twitter
so that's no problem
see you later bro